jean françois lépine que vous connaissez
bien jean françois bon soir au flore pas
pris on va essayer de démêler tout ça
d'abord premières réactions des chinois
au tout début je remonte il y a trois
semaines on est prudent et on appuie
pendu pas bravo mais en même temps
dénoncent pas
avant les jeux olympiques si on se
souvient bien le président c'est jean
ping a reçu dans une rencontre vraiment
officiel importante à l'ouverture dès
avant l'ouverture des jeux le président
poutine on a sont allés faire des
déclarations d'amitié de solidarité
commune et tout ça et après ça on n'a
pas cessé la chine a été inondés
d'informations complètement
contradictoires à ce qu'on entend ici
sur ce qui se passait vraiment la chine
a commencé par parler de crise plutôt
que de guerre ensuite on a parlé d'une
dune à d'une attaque défensive de la
part de lave de la russie on n'a jamais
montré au public chinois les tentes de
réfugiés les les dommages causés par les
bombardements russes mais tout ça est en
train un petit peu de changer on pourra
parler de tous les aspects de ça mais
vous l'avez dit vous-même c'est
compliqué de comprendre la situation de
la chine parce que la chine est en train
en plus de chambres est actuellement
puis je peux vous dire qu'il ya mardi
dernier dans le washington post
l'ambassadeur chinois à washington a
pris la tête de de publier l'étranglant
c'est vrai que en reconnaissant que la
position chinoise était pas clair en
disant d'abord on ne savait pas donc
quand monsieur poutine a rencontré six
genting on ne savait pas l'ampleur de ce
qui allait se passer et on n'a pas non
plus demandé à poutine de reporter son
attaque après les jules sosthène une
accusation faisait aussi à la chine donc
donc on n'a pas offert d'armes à la
chine et à la russie et on à frire à pas
dans ma la russie donc démenti de toute
cette histoire là aussi dans le
washington post il ya deux jours donc
lui l'ambassadeur des on veut mais on
veut la fin de la guerre donc on emploie
maintenant en tulle le terme guerre les
évolutions quel intérêt la chine aurait
eu ou aurait à aider poutine que ce soit
financièrement pas ça lui coûte une
fortune cette guerre poutine ou
militaires mais quel intérêt y aurait
la russie est un allié important de la
chine parce que les deux pays se sentent
un peu victime de démarches de la part
des pays alliés des pays occidentaux y
compris du japon de d'essayer de bloquer
leur développement il ya cette espèce de
paranoïa commune il ya aussi des
échanges commerciaux importants entre
les deux pays des alliances sur le plan
militaire aussi les chinois ont dans
depuis 2009 sans depuis 2010 7 80% de
leurs importations militaires viennent
de russie dont tiens il ya là un lien
très important importations issues de
céréales un gros importateur de céréales
russes et d'énergie d'hydrocarbures en
provenance de russie donc des
partenaires qui sont solides mais là le
comportement de vladimir poutine mais
les chinois dans l'embarras puis je peux
vous expliquer pourquoi justement est ce
qu est ce que ce sont des craintes de
sanctions économiques qui viendrait de
l'europe des etats-unis vis-à-vis la
chaîne qui qui font réfléchir les
chinois actuellement
d'abord les chinois ne s'attendait pas à
une guerre comme celle là en plein coeur
de l'europe l'europe pour la chine fait
le client est le partenaire commercial
le plus important au monde
les chinois ne veulent pas de fragilité
dans ça et ne veulent pas surtout d'un
conflit qui pourrait s'étendre sur la
planète et qui crée une déstabilisation
majeure public la chine a une obsession
elle veut devenir le plus rapidement
possible la plus grande puissance
mondiale en chine ça va bien et le
président civil thein qui va solliciter
l'automne prochain troisième mandat
c'est pas permis vraiment en vertu de la
tradition politique récente en chine il
veut un troisième mandat c'est mal vu
dans son pays il a beau - de stabilité
et il s'attendait certainement pas à une
opération comme celle là de la part de
la russie qui déstabilise non seulement
la région l'europe au complet mais aussi
la planète on en parle tous les jours
est-ce que jean-françois s'il mettait
tout son poids peut-il selon vous
faire reculer poutine alors il ya
différentes choses qui se disent et qui
qu'on peut observer c'est que
l'administration chinoise a tellement
monté la population chinoise contre le
temps contre les partenaires européens
contre les alliés et pour la russie
comment maintenant et c'est le problème
apparemment du président six unités
comment peut-il se positionner comme
quelqu'un qui va obtenir de vladimir
poutine des concessions donc une victoie
moindre que ce que poutine voudrait
avoir et donc comment expliquerait s'il
commence easing expliquera tout ça a une
population chinoise qui est vraiment
monté une contre l'otan c'est la faute
de l'otan c'est notre faute ce qui se
passe et c'est pas la cote de poutine
c'est comme ça que les chinois voient
les choses actuellement alors donc oui
il a il à ces difficultés-là intervenir
mais c'est évident que si monsieur xi
jingping rejoignait le concert des
alliés pour mettre des présents surtout
aux nations unies 1le la chine s'est
abstenue aux nations unies pourtant la
chine après cette fondamentale il faut
respecter la souveraineté et le
territoire des états en soldes dans le
monde la chaîne a intérêt à ça parce
qu'elle veut qu'on restait que le sien
est simple ans est fondamental pour les
chinois pourtant ils acceptent
ouvertement depuis 20 jours ce qui se
passe actuellement du quartier tous il
faut dire un partenaire commercial très
important de la chine alors ce deux
poids deux mesures là est d'ailleurs
l'ambassadeur chinois a dit dans sa
lettre ce que les chinois disent battant
aujourd'hui on n'a pas vu la couleur ça
que là maintenant il ya l'humanite de
donald humanitaire sud doivent s'en va
vers les ukrainiens entre des
couvertures alors c'est ça changera pas
beaucoup les choses mais s'il veut
intervenir c'est sûr que la chine a un
tel poids auprès de moscou cela masque
ou serait quand même assez découragés du
concert des nations qui force ou kiev
cette force et la russie à faire des
compromis et surtout à faire à cette
dernière question jean-françois vente
vous laisser aller taiwan dès le jour 1
les gens ont dit si
on les chinois reconnaissait les
préoccupations de poutine pour avoir
pour être maître chez lui est ce à dire
que taiwan se serait il y aurait la
route une carte routière pour envahir
taiwan pour les chiens est-ce qu'on peut
faire un rapport ou pas on peut faire un
rapport certainement parce que les
chinois revit que taiwan va revenir dans
le giron de la chine
la seule différence est que taiwan n'est
pas considérée par la chine comme un
pays indépendant
en fait considéré comme une province qui
fait qui a quitté la chine et que la
chaîne veut revoir dans son giron mais
ce qui a changé parce qu'effectivement
je disais moi même au début de
l'offensive russe que les choix observe
étroitement 6 pas parce que d'autres se
disent qu'un jour il ya une déclaration
d'indépendance à taiwan et qu'on veut
forcer la note et on veut envahir taïwan
comment le monde va-t-il réagir ce qu'on
dit maintenant même en chine et que la
force de la réaction des alliés de
l'ukraine la forte des sanctions
économiques est telle que les chinois se
disent oh que se passerait-il si on pose
est ce juste donc c'est pas tellement
une menace militaire encore que vous
pouvez voir la résistance des
ukrainiennes l'aide militaire qu'on
apporte aux ukrainiens qu'est ce que ça
va donner mais les chinois observe
vraiment cette situation-là est de toute
évidence de plus en plus de gens au
niveau du leadership chinois qui ont une
certaine influence auprès du site jean
ping qui lui disent peut-être que tu as
tu aurais intérêt à calmer le jeu avant
qu'on que les alliés d'hier d'autres
leçons de ce conflit dont il pourrait
éventuellement s'appliquer à nous et
c'est vraiment pour ça que la chine a
une attitude qui est vraiment en train
de changer actuelle jean-françois les
peines très intéressante toujours un
plaisir de vous parler merci jean
françois et moi qui ont bien plus à lui